um Greedo just got out shout out to
Greedo I was just with him uh two days
ago I just shot a video of him yeah
shout out to him for his song uh no for
the [__] I got on the project okay uh
it's a games with me him and bino uh
obviously TK's burritos manager used to
manage you
um how dope is it to kind of see him
come out because yeah I think we kind of
like didn't know how long it was going
to be gone you know God even even when
he was coming out it was like a surprise
yeah it was like damn he's out and he's
in Texas
um how like just talk about your
relationship with him like obviously you
know I feel like he's I feel like him
and Draco are and you guys very
influential and everything happened so I
know me and him was just talking about
it when I seen him the other day because
we haven't seen each other in [__]
years right that was the first time
we've seen each other and we were just
talking about everything how we changed
everything and uh yeah that's my boy
that's like me and him got a real
friendship right yeah yeah I feel like
we me and my boy Salis were just talking
about just like there's guys in L.A
whose influence is so crazy
that like if you aren't from here you
really don't have like any idea you know
not for real it's almost like people in
like the bay yeah
super like that I don't think I think
you kind of got to be from debate I
understand like the Mac Dre thing like
fully you know for sure so that's the
same thing with Greedo and I I mean you
guys you guys have some crazy world
tours
are you gonna be uh for this album are
you
you know going crazy on the content
going crazy on the videos yeah we we
doing uh I'm gonna try to shoot as many
videos as this label gonna [__] give
me money to shoot right so I'll shoot as
many of those and then the concert we
doing all the tick tock and [__] I feel
like I'm gonna be in the hang of tick
tock right now how do you get the hang
of tick tock because it's [__] it's
the I hope they ban it I guess just
using it my Tick Tock going crazy right
now I think I got like 300 400 000
followers in the last two months are you
doing your own tick tocks uh the label's
helping me with it but we kind of just
piecing together my own content that me
and my [__] camera got shoot so are
you hoping to get spanned too so it's
one less thing you have to work no hell
no because now I got it going I just
like now if you got deleted from the
world I'm like thank God I feel like
taking is changing the whole [__]
music for good or bad for bad yeah I
feel like it's all types of people
getting popping off one song and just
like
and then they signed a deal for a single
and then they go away yeah yeah it's a
bunch of tick tock is crazy it's crazy
because then you got guys like yourself
who like are kind of like
backward reversing yeah I'm trying to
figure out already popping yeah I'm
trying to figure out how to get more
popular
yeah no what is it if you could give
anybody any advice about Tick Tock what
kind of content should they be doing if
they're up with somebody I don't know I
need to learn what kind of content well
you got [__] 300 000 followers
something you're doing is working I'm
just posting like random [__] I'm
already like an established artist I
feel like you are so it's just like
everything's just adding to my to my
[__] yo would you and YG why'd you do
the whole album with mozzie you got
share management would you and why'd you
ever do a project together uh uh I would
be done oh yeah we got to do some rest
of that [__] you guys have a bunch of
unreleased music together no no that
would be crazy yeah it would be crazy
that [__] was hard as [__] I feel like
you got y'all got to take it back to
like just read up that's right yeah we
gotta do some ratchet [__] yeah so
mustard mustard got to do it mustard
unless they got to do that [__] 100 have
you ever worked with mustard uh yeah he
did a trap house I mean oh he did okay
that [__] wouldn't go that's crazy man
shout out to mustard [__] on the way to
being Platinum mustard is a
one of them once man yeah
um any who else anybody else dope
handling production on this album uh I
got production from all types of people
on this one
I'm trying to think I don't even
remember I was just getting everybody
was just sending me [__] in so you're
just like [__] it I'm not yeah you know
what that's I like that and I was on so
you know I did a lot of this album on
tour on the bus yeah on the bus I did
some in The Green Room you're recording
The Green Room yeah that shit's crazy
yeah
what kind of mic you taking on the road
uh I don't know what type of what type
of mic I got
I don't know women you 87 I have no idea
I think the u87 that sounds familiar
that's funny
um yo so talk to me about like uh you
know for you man I do feel like
when we look at like the landscape of La
hip-hop
I think you've done a really good job of
branching out and like working with
people outside of the region and like
kind of breaking through because I do
feel like a lot of Cali rappers like you
listen to the music and you'll kind of
recognize that there is like kind of
like a ceiling on like the type of [__]
they're doing or the type of artists
that they're working with for you was it
like always like a conscious decision
for you to kind of like expand outside
of Cali in terms of like networking
doing records with people to kind of
make sure you didn't fall into that lane
where you're just I feel like it wasn't
like a conscious decision I just I just
did like what I like and I make music
with the people that I listen to you
feel me so I always listen to [__] from
every other reason and every other place
in the world so that was that's how that
went yeah
um who's who's somebody because I feel
like you're kind of always up on the new
[__] who's somebody who's popping who's
like you know that you're you're [__]
with it that maybe the rest of the world
ain't up on who's the most let me see I
[__] with uh bro that's coming out of
here [__] from the West Coast uh him
busy he hard yeah he's dope shout out to
uh he's from San Bernardino right I
don't know where you're from he's from
yeah he's from uh I think he's from
that's the guy who canceled on us like
three times yeah
have you heard this dude big X the plug
from Dallas no [__] he's hard
bro have you heard him bro he's fired if
it was super crazy yeah he's busy I
think he's from uh he's from that or
he's no he's from San Bernardino this
was somewhere out here yeah for sure
yeah
um